in the world Putin is exacting Vengeance
for his military failures on the
civilians of Ukraine by cutting off
their power and their water supply and
on the poorest people in the world by
threatening Their Food Supplies over 60
percent of the wheat exported under the
Black Sea grain initiative has gone to
low and middle income countries
including Ethiopia Yemen and Afghanistan
it would be unconscionable for those
lands to be made to suffer because of
Putin's setbacks on the battlefield in
Ukraine I urge Russia to stop impeding
this vital initiative that is helping
feed the hungry across the world and
agree to its extension meanwhile
Russia's suicide drones and cruise
missiles are killing Ukrainian civilians
obliterating their homes and even
destroying a children's playground a
third of the country's power stations
were put out of operation in a single
week none of this achieves any military
purpose Putin's only aim is to spread
Terror and to deprive Ukrainian families
of shelter light and heat as harsh
winter approaches
I'm sure the house will join me in
condemning his breaches of international
humanitarian law I'm sure every
honorable and right honorable member
will share my conviction that Putin will
never break the spirit of the Ukrainian
people and this house will share my
incredulity at the glaring
contradictions in Putin's thinking he
claims that Russia sorry he claims that
Ukraine is part of Russia and the
ukrainians are Russians but at the same
time he calls them Nazis who must be
bombed without Mercy
when he launched his invasion he
convinced himself that Russian forces
would be welcomed in Kiev
and he would either and they would
either support him or
be too Craven to stand in his way he
could not have been more wrong the last
eight months has shown the scale of his
miscalculation
they have shown the barbarity of his
Onslaught including the mass rape
committed by Russian soldiers in Ukraine
the UK's campaign to prevent sexual
violence in conflict is more urgent now
than ever and I will host a conference
on this vital subject next month
and now the Kremlin is resorting to
peddling false claims churning out
invented stories that say more about the
fractures within the Russian government
than they do about us it is re it is
also reprehensible that Iran should have
supplied Russia with the Shahid drones
that are bringing destruction to Ukraine
in violation of U.N resolution 2231.
on the 20th of October the government
imposed sanctions on three Iranian
commanders involved in supplying
Weaponry to Russia along with the
company that manufactures shahead drones
earlier Putin announced on the 30th
September that Russia had annexed four
regions of Ukraine spanning 40 000
square miles the biggest land grab in
Europe since the Second World War once
again
this exposes his self-delusion Putin has
declared the annexation of territory he
has not captured and what he had managed
to seize he is in the process of losing
on the 12th of October
143 countries three-quarters of the
entire membership of the United Nations
voted in the general assembly to condemn
the annexation
Russia had just four supporters
Syria
Belarus Nicaragua North Korea
and when those regimes are your only
friends you really know that you are
isolated
when 141 countries denounced Putin's
Invasion back in March some speculated
that that was the ceiling of the
international support for Ukraine
the latest vote showed even more nations
are now ready to condemn Russia but
Putin still thinks that by forcing up
food and energy prices we will lose our
resolve our task
is to prove him wrong
we will not waver in our support for
Ukraine's right to self-defense
I delivered that emphatic message when I
spoke to my Ukrainian counterpart on
Tuesday and my right honorable friend
the Prime Minister said the same to
president zielinski when they spoke on
the phone the first foreign leader that
he called upon his appointment as prime
minister
on Thursday I will attend a meeting of
G7 foreign ministers in Germany where I
will send a unified signal of our shared
determination
Britain gave Ukraine 2.3 billion pounds
worth of Military Support more than any
country in the world apart from the
United States of America we will provide
Ukraine with more support to repair its
energy infrastructure and we have
committed to 220 million pounds of
humanitarian Aid the house will have
noted Putin's irresponsible talk about
nuclear weapons and an absurd claim the
Ukraine plans to detonate a radiological
dirty bomb on its own territory no other
country is talking about nuclear use no
country is threatening Russia or
threatening President Putin he should be
clear
that for the UK and our allies
any use at all of nuclear weapons would
fundamentally change the nature of this
conflict there would be severe
consequences for Russia
and how counterproductive would it be
for Russia to break a norm against
nuclear use that has held since 1945 and
has underpinned Global Security
nothing will alter our conviction that
the ukrainians have a right to live in
Peace and Freedom in their own lands
if Putin were to succeed every
expansionist Tyrant would be emboldened
to do their worst and no country would
be safe that is why we stand and will
continue to stand alongside our
Ukrainian friends until the day comes as
it inevitably will that they prevail
Mr Speaker I commend the statements to
the house
shut up for his secretary David
[Applause]
Mr Speaker the war in Ukraine is at a
critical new stage
increasing missile and drone attacks the
senseless withdrawal from the grain
export deal that would lead to
increasing hunger around the world and
as we enter the winter months Putin's
rhetoric is becoming increasingly
irresponsible
including his references to nuclear
weapons and dangerous Fabrications
around a so-called dirty bomb
and I support the foreign secretary's
words on that matter
this is a sign of Putin's desperation
but this does not mean
an end is near
this will be a long and protracted
conflict
this morning more than 50 missiles were
launched by Russian forces against
Ukrainian energy and Water Systems over
the course of just a few hours
this isn't an isolated attack but a
deliberate and callous Russian strategy
to Target civilian infrastructure ahead
of the winter Mr Speaker some estimates
claim almost a third of Ukraine's power
stations and other energy facilities
have been hit and eighty percent of Kiev
has been left without water after these
latest attacks
the foreign secretary mentioned his
discussions with our ambassador on the
ground I am sure the whole house are
grateful to the Embassy team for their
continuing work in very challenging
conditions
can the foreign secretary set out today
how many electricity generators the UK
has already sent to Ukraine and how we
will strengthen Ukraine's energy Supply
at this time
some of these attacks have been
conducted using Iranian supplied drones
we welcome the sanctions already
announced against the Iranian regime
what further measures is the government
considering to prevent Iran's material
support to Russia's invasion
over the past week we've also seen
Russia engage in baseless ridiculous
accusations that the United Kingdom was
involved in the destruction of part of
the Nordstrom pipeline what is the
government doing to tackle the dangerous
disinformation being spread by Putin
Mr Speaker the U.N backed agreement on
grain exports has been vital in reducing
Global food prices President Putin's
unjustifiable decision to pull out of
the steel will have catastrophic
consequences it comes at a time when
many countries are already food insecure
including Somalia where an imminent
famine is feared this decision should be
seen by the world for what it is the
kremlin's cruel and transparent use of
hunger to Blackmail
any spike in world food prices will be
the responsibility of the Russian
government an agreement must be restored
can the foreign secretary outline what
conversations he's had with counterparts
including turkey on the potential for
restoring grain flows and what steps the
UK is considering to mitigate the worst
consequences for the developing world if
those efforts fail
since the end of August Ukraine has been
conducting successful counter-offensive
operations in the south and east of
Ukraine liberating around 12 000 square
kilometers but Russia continues to
attempt to make progress in the dombas
and batmoot
winter is coming any counter offenses
could soon slow and an operational
stalemate is likely for the next couple
of months it is day 249 of the invasion
and the ministry of Defense has not even
signed a contract to replenish the end
laws anti-tank missiles which has been
vital to the Ukrainian Army
will the government restock and resupply
Ukraine and the British Armed Forces
with essential military assistance over
20 NATO countries have now rebooted
defense plants since the invasion begun
but the UK government has still not done
so will he update the integrated review
of the foreign and defense policy and
continue what was indicated by the last
prime minister now we are on our third
in just three months
Mr Speaker last month the U.N at the
United Nations more countries than ever
voted to condemn Russia in its illegal
and unjustifiable annexation of
Ukrainian territory the world saw
through the Sham referendums and
recognized Russia's actions as a
flagrant violation of the UN Charter we
must sustain and grow The Diplomatic
Coalition against Putin because the
outcome of this war will depend on who
is more resilient Putin's Russia or
Ukraine and its supporters in the west
and Beyond labor is clear we won't let
our support for Ukraine falter our duty
now is to make sure Ukraine wins this
means providing the Diplomatic and
Military Support required but also
moving beyond ad hoc announcements and
laying out a long-term strategy for
military economic and diplomatic
assistance through 2023 and Beyond we
have to reinforce the message to Putin
continuing this barbaric war will make
make it worse not better for Russia
for a secretary
I think the uh I think my uh sorry my
opposite number the right honorable
gentleman for the points that he's made
and echoing from his benches the support
for uh the Ukrainian people and their
attempts to or their work to eject
Russia from their homelands I think it
is noticed that whilst we often disagree
sometime on detail our
Collective response is to support the
Ukrainian people that will be noted and
I think they will be incredibly grateful
for that he raises a number of points
which I will attempt to cover in my
response in terms of the energy needs of
the Ukrainian people going into the
winter the UK has pledged 100 million
pounds to support Ukraine's energy
security and to reform and 74 million in
fiscal grants to support Ukraine through
the World Bank with his specific
question about the number of generators
I will see
um get more details of that and share
those with him at an appropriate point
in the future
with regard to Iran he notes the fact
that we have already sanctioned a number
of people as I made in a point I made in
my statement he will know that we do not
discuss future sanctions designations
but I can assure him that we will be
keeping a close eye on Iran and indeed
any other countries actions in terms of
providing arms for Russia and we will
take appropriate actions to dissuade
them from doing so and to react if they
do he is absolutely right to highlight
the situation with regard to
disinformation we have seen increasingly
desperate statements coming out of uh
the Russian Ministry of defense and the
Kremlin
those claims are designed to distract
the Russian people and indeed The Wider
International Community from the truth
and the truth is that the ukrainians are
pushing Russian forces back on the
battlefield we must not be distracted
from that truth and he is absolutely
right that we must work with our
International allies to make sure that
Russia's disinformation campaign does
not influence global support for the uh
for the Ukrainian people he also
mentioned grain exports and I've spoken
with my Turkish counterparts in the past
uh
expressing our gratitude for the work
that they've done securing that grain
export deal and we've also reinforced
the need for that to be extended and for
Russia to to lift the the pause on their
engagement with that this is about
ensuring
that the global uh poor
those people who are already suffering
from Hunger are not drawn into a
conflict not of their choosing and we
must not let Vladimir Putin use Global
hunger as Leverage
to undermine support for the ukrainians
in the defense of their homelands he
makes he asks about the supply of
anti-tank missile systems we are
committed to matching our support next
year as we have done for this year we
will ensure that the ukrainians are
supplied with the arms most relevant to
the needs at the time obviously in the
initial conflict the initial phases of
the conflict those in-laws and other
anti-tank missile systems were
incredibly imp important to them what
we're now seeing as the battlefield has
evolved
ground-to-air missile systems and
air-to-air missile systems have
increased in importance we'll make sure
that our support to Ukraine matches
their needs but we'll also ensure that
we don't Denude our own armed forces of
requirements and action has been taken
to stimulate the supply chain for
critical and military equipment we will
always ensure that we adapt to the
circumstances on the ground on the
battlefield and also ensure that we
don't as I say to noon ourselves our
ability to defend this country as well
as our friends and allies yeah according
to the show the select committee Alicia
Keys speaker
a ground we most
we most a wage and therefore he's
[Music]
he's been Ukraine's children so can my
right on my friend tell me what
conversations he's having with
abstentionist countries who are most
likely to suffer from famine in order to
incur that they encourage Russia to
return to the Black Sea grain deal on
the kidnapping of Ukrainian children
which is a form of genocide there
appears to be no meaningful
International action taking place so can
he reassure us on that front and finally
Bell and cat have identified 33
individuals whose sole job is to Target
civilian infrastructure within Ukraine
can he reassure us that sanctions are
being considered against these
individuals whose sole job is to
terrorize the Ukrainian public
thank you
for a section I think my honorable
friend for the uh the points that she
has made and she is uh absolutely right
that it is important that we engage with
those countries that have thus far
abstained in votes at the United Nations
to remind them that Russia's attack on
Ukraine the invasion of Ukraine is not
just a European issue it is about the UN
Charter it is about territorial
Integrity it is about the rule of law
and that any and all countries that
value those things should be should show
solidarity in their condemnation of
Russia's involvement she asks about uh
individuals that may be involved in
targeting of Civilian infrastructure she
will understand of course that we don't
discuss intelligence matters and also we
don't go into detail about future
sanctions designations but I can assure
her that we think very carefully we act
very carefully in terms of our response
to to deter
but also to respond to those
the issues that she has raised and we
will of course keep a very very close
eye on the actions of Russia where they
are targeting civilians and civilian
infrastructure as well as critical
National infrastructure and that will
always be an important part of the work
we do I send peace first person I don't
care
thank you Mr Speaker renewed cruise
missile attacks or Ukrainian cities in
civilian infrastructure this morning are
appalling but tragically now part of
Putin's almost daily Arsenal by
attacking residential areas electricity
infrastructure in Water Supplies Putin
is ordering his trips to carry out War
climbs on a daily basis and then as an
International Community we cannot allow
this to happen so can a foreign
secretary give detail about what is
being done to assist diplomats on the
ground in Ukraine including UK diplomats
document war crimes and claims Against
Humanity committed by the Russian
military so that these incidents can be
escalated to the ICC
aslis wore morphs into a protracted
conflict the creep of Ukraine fatigue
into the UK public is an increasing
danger so the statistics published
recently show that in the midst of the
hike the UK Energy prices UK public
support for continuing economic
sanctions against Russia has fallen from
73 in March to 41 in this month so what
is the UK government doing to mitigate
against Ukraine fatigue while the UK
government commit to a public campaign
to remain the electorate a why we're
supporting Ukraine and B what they can
continue doing to help
food security is also of grave concern
12 grade export shifts have left Ukraine
today despite Russia pulling out off the
turkey U.N brokered Grand deal so the
need for Reliable green supplies Madam
Deputy speaker particularly in regions
such as the Horn of Africa is acute as
the aggressor in this war Russia has
already made itself an international
Pariah and it cannot continue to do so
by actively restricting Food Supplies to
farming and drought effective regions of
the world so can the foreign secretary
outline the steps that the fcdo is
taking alongside International allies to
get Russian officials back into talks
for this deal and while he also
confirmed whether UK officials are
assisting Turkish counterparts in their
efforts in securing this green deal and
finally can he give the house details
about the sanctions on Iran given their
supplies of drones to Russia against
Ukraine and have targeted civilians and
he said earlier answer to the shop
reporting secretary that he quite
greatly won't give detail but can commit
to giving regular updates to the house
yeah
so true State there was a speaker uh The
Honorable lady raises a number of very
uh important points with regard to Iran
I can assure her that we constantly
review our sanctions uh policy sorry uh
our sanctions designations and we will
we will ensure that we respond to any
further breaches of the U.N security
Council resolution about supplying arms
to this conflict
she makes an incredibly important point
about the documentation of war crimes I
had meetings with Kareem Khan either the
international criminal court the two
prosecutes of the international criminal
court with regards to documentation of
war crimes to ensure that those
perpetrators know that they will be held
to account for the actions that they
have taken and with regards to the UK's
support for Ukraine we recognize that
this winter will be tough for people
here in the UK
our energy support package is designed
to alleviate some of that pressure but
we recognize it will be tough
but I think the British people
instinctively understand that if we if
we slip back
from our support of the ukrainians in
this incredibly difficult time for them
the costs globally will be huge the cost
in lives the cost and Food Supplies the
cost in energy supplies and their costs
to families here in the UK so as
difficult as it is and I recognize that
it is difficult for everyone at this
time it is essential that we continue
our support for Ukraine because the cost
of inaction will be so much higher
Vicki Ford
thank you madam Deputy speaker
tens of thousands of people have been
affected by this war directly and
thousands of Ukrainian innocent
civilians have lost their lives it's
absolutely right that the UK remains
steadfast and unwavering in our support
for the people of Ukraine we will be
with them as long as they need us but
globally as my right home foreign
sectors said many millions of the
world's most vulnerable have been pushed
deeper into hunger and starvation and
even famine by Putin's war on food I was
very pleased to hear my right honorable
friends are reminding of the fact that
the majority of the grain that has come
out of the Black Sea has gone too low
and middle income countries because
Russian misinformation is trying to tell
the world that the opposite
so can I urge my right on the friend and
his team of excellent ministers to use
all diplomatic tools to try and get that
Black Sea grain initiative not only back
up and running but also extended and to
continue to call out the Russian
misinformation on this point
Secretary of State of this speaker I'd
like to put on record my thanks to my
right honorable friend for the work that
she did in her time at the foreign
Commonwealth and development office and
the uh huge energy that she brought to
the role she's absolutely right that we
are witnessing the perverse situation
where Vladimir Putin is trying to impose
even greater hunger on people who are
already suffering food insecurity and in
some instances uh famine
and he's absolutely wrong that he does
so and we call upon Russia to resume the
Black Sea grain deal and to extend it it
is it is deeply deeply wrong that the
world's poor are forced to suffer even
more because
Russia has been and is being
unsuccessful on the battlefield I can
assure her that we will continue working
with turkey and others to get that deal
back in place
you said
Chris Bryant
um one of the most depressing things
upsetting things I've seen in the last
few days is Russian conscripts
in floods of Tears saying I don't want
to be Cannon frauder I'm just going to
be Cannon for it so this is a crime
against Russian people as well yeah and
but can I just ask about the sanction
regime in the UK because it does seem a
bit of a known goal and
counterproductive there's significant
people are being sanctioned by the UK
are allowed to have 60 000 pounds a
month one and a half million pounds to
spend on luxurious Lifestyles here and
and can you just update us on what's
happened to the 3.5 billion pounds from
abramovich's sale of Chelsea which was
meant to be going already by now to the
Reconstruction of Ukraine it's not true
state
um I'm deaf speaker I can assure The
Honorable gentleman that we will
continue to work with our International
counterparts to make sure that our
sanctions uh are effective as effective
as they can be and to continue putting
pressure on those people who are funding
uh Russia's illegal and unprovoked war
in Ukraine I will seek to get further
details on the specific points that he
has raised with regards sanctions he's
absolutely right he is absolutely right
that in addition to the terrible
suffering that ukrainians are
experiencing because of Putin's invasion
of Ukraine
Russians are also suffering there are
mothers who thought their sons were
going to a training exercise who now
have found out that those soldiers have
been killed on the battlefield Putin has
blood on his hands Ukrainian blood
Russian blood it is down to him and
almost no one else
Julian Lewis
speaker given the emphasis that Putin is
putting on attacking infrastructure and
without in any way asking him to be
specific will the foreign secretary
reassure the house that enough attention
is being paid by our Armed Forces to
protecting undersea pipelines and
internet cables and will he have a quiet
word between now and the Autumn
statement with the Prime Minister and
the chancellor to say that now is not
the right time to be rowing back from a
long overdue promise to increase
expenditure on defense
foreign
State uh my right honorable friend
tempts me
could go beyond my brief at the dispatch
box all I can say is that I always
listen to his advice carefully and I
have no doubt that the Secretary of
State for defense the Prime Minister
indeed the chancellor will have all have
listened very very carefully to the
points
Tony Lloyd
is quite right to make the points about
protection of the infrastructure in
Ukraine because we know the campaign at
the moment is to weaken the morale of
the Ukrainian people is he satisfied
though in that context there is the
international coordination so that we're
making sure that the British efforts
efforts from other International
partners are such that it does deliver
the support the Ukraine needs at the
moment
such a state he makes a very important
Point Vladimir Putin clearly went into
this conflict believing that the
pressure he exerted on Ukraine would
create fragmentation in the Ukrainian
political system it did not he was
expecting it would create tension in
NATO it did not he thought it would
split up the EU it did not he thought it
would break up the G7 it did not at
every single strategic aim he has failed
indeed he is now looking at a stronger
and larger NATO because of his actions I
can assure uh The Honorable gentleman
that the International Community if
anything has been brought closer
together in terms of our coordinated uh
response to you Russia's invasion of
Ukraine and in terms of our support of
the ukrainians themselves
friend made clear that if indeed any
attack did take place on the Russian
Black Sea Fleet the UK had absolutely no
involvement in it and can he confirm
that despite the withdrawal of Russia
from the agreement nevertheless ships
have left Odessa today uh bearing grain
and can he say whether or not he expects
that to continue
such a state uh my right honorable
friend makes a very very important point
about the importance of the Black Sea
grain deal
that is that is helping feed people that
need the international support now more
than ever
um with regard to the claims that are
being made from the Kremlin and the
Russian Ministry of Defense they are
becoming uh
increasingly detached uh from reality
and as I've said they are designed to
distract the Russian people from the
reality of the Russian failures on the
battlefield we will continue to shine a
light on those failures and we'll
continue to support Ukraine in defending
itself against that aggression Hillary
Ben thank you very much Madam Deputy
speaker it announcing he was pulling out
of the deal
Russia said it would be risky for
Ukraine to continue to seek to export
Ukraine using the Black Sea given that
the only possible risk to ships comes
from Russia itself and further to the
question just put by the writerable
member for Malden
if ships are moving out of Odessa there
are reports that the United Nations
turkey and Ukraine have reached some
agreement about ships that are currently
in Turkish Waters
does she think there's any prospect that
President Putin's Bluff on this will be
called ships will continue to be
inspected by the other parties to the
agreement and they can carry on helping
to feed the world
social States uh I think the point he
made about where the only credible
threat to international shipping would
come from is an important one
and I think the world would see
if those green ships were attacked or if
they were prevented from exporting that
grain the world would see who was
ultimately responsible for imposing even
further hunger on those people in the
world those people in the global South
those were people already suffering from
food insecurity and famine the world
would see who was truly to blame for
imposing greater hardship on those
people who are already suffering
to myself
can I absolutely endorse the support
that this front this government the
front bench is giving to Ukraine but
we've entered a darker chapter as Putin
is up against the wall he's resorting to
non-conventional means can I suggest
that our support therefore needs to move
bear in mind the escalator ladder from
the battlefield to supporting Ukraine's
infrastructure and to that end Odessa
that critical Port those grain ships are
not getting out to the scale that we
need to to feed the world could I
suggest that he takes goes to the United
Nations General Assembly secures a
resolution to create a safe haven around
that Port so Britain can lead the
International Community in Maritime
flatilla to support the grain ships
departing and entering that port
such as States my rights will be friend
makes an incredibly important point
about the uh significance of grain
exports from the Black Sea I've listened
to uh his proposal I think that what we
need to do is uh is see Russia
immediately
reverse its pause on its involvement in
Black Sea exports and we will look at
any options which increase the flow of
food to the global South to the people
who need that food more than ever of
course I will take his uh suggestion
seriously but ultimately we want to do
whatever we can do to increase the grain
exports immediately
Kevin Robinson
speaker and can I thank the foreign
secretary for his statement and in
recognizing the answers he has given
already about sanctions for the irgc
encourage him to recognize her across
the house there will be support for
further action should he deem it fit to
take and I would encourage him to do so
in respect of the United Nations I think
it is encouraging to hear the
understanding by ship movements today
but could he elaborate from a diplomatic
perspective what Avenues are available
through the United Nations to increase
international support bearing in mind
the veto that Russia continues to have
in the P5
such a state I'm Dave speaking he makes
an incredibly important point about the
inbuilt limitations of the United
Nations because of Russia's abuse of its
veto the United Nations an incredibly
important institution and as they say
the world
143 countries voting in condemnation of
annexation 141 voting in condemnation of
the attack we we know the United Nations
is still an incredibly important
institution but Russia's veto limits in
some extent to some extent what it can
do so therefore we will continue to work
uh with the UN with turkey and others to
maximize the grain exports through the
Black Sea so we can alleviate the hunger
felt by the global South
James Sunderland
speaker thank you
I'm sure that every person in the house
today will share my own horror and
revulsion at the continual targeting by
Russia of non-combatants and also
lobbing of missiles into civilian areas
noting the limitations indirectly posed
by Article 5 could the foreign secretary
please confirm whether any consideration
has been given to the deployment of an
Iron Dome or Patriot type system to
protect newtonians
such a state
uh the UK and our International allies
have provided Ukraine with both ground
to air defense systems and also
air-to-air defense systems we will
continue to assess their defense needs
and adjust our support to them
accordingly
Grant Davis
that's my name Deputy speaker president
of zelinski at the Council of Europe uh
which I'm a member of suggested that
they only had about 10 percent of the
air defenses needed to to respond to the
current Onslaught a lot of that
onslaughts of course from Iranian drones
so given that Iran is in a condition of
social unrest what efforts has the UK
government making to ensure that people
in Iran know that the focus of their
government is to set and weapons of mass
destruction to against innocent people
rather than feeding them bread and
giving them human rights in order to
choke off over over time the supply of
these deadly weapons
uh he makes a very good point we will
continue to take action which discourage
the supply of weapons to Russia that
will be used that might be used in
Ukraine and we'll keep under constant
review our sanctions packages to uh to
choke off the supply of weapons like
drugs keep it under review
Wendy Morton are you madam Deputy
speaker my right honorable friend has
set out what he is doing to urge allies
and other countries to provide extra
support for Ukraine but specifically
when it comes to the training of those
brave ukrainians are fighting in their
homelands I wonder if he could set out
what more we can do perhaps working with
our NATO allies in this regard
um I'm depressed speaker I'm very proud
that I'm joined on the front bench by uh
my uh right honorable and Gallant friend
from Ministry of Defense I'm incredibly
proud of the work that the British armed
forces have done training members of the
Ukrainian Armed Forces we are being
joined by an increasingly large number
of international allies who are doing
likewise I think it is being
demonstrated on the battlefield that
it's not just the equipment that we have
supplied or the inherent resolve of the
Ukrainian Armed Forces but also the
technical Improvement that we have
helped train uh with the Ukrainian armed
forces that has been decisive I have no
doubt that will continue
Leila Moran
Deputy speaker may I thank the foreign
secretary for his words and particularly
agree with when he says we will not
allow Putin to use hunger AS Global
leverage because doing so is barbaric
and frankly condemns thousands more to
death than he's already killed
but given that backdrop does he also
share my concern
that we as a country are now only
spending 0.3 percent of gross national
income on Aid across the world we found
this out this weekend we have all here
campaigned on manifestos of 0.7
surely the answer now is for us to step
up again and ensure that what Putin
wants to do cannot be done because we
will be there to ensure that his
barbaric act won't have the effect he
hopes
I I don't agree with the uh the figures
that The Honorable lady has used but the
broader fact is that we continue
to support countries uh in the the
global South poor countries around the
world we continue to support them
directly but also through ensuring that
those grain exports uh continue we are
helping them uh through the Black Sea
grain initiative and I can assure her
and the house that we will continue to
do both it is incredibly important that
we re-establish the principle the
powerful neighbors cannot invade another
country with impunity that territorial
Integrity must be
preserved because it will be the very
people that she makes reference to in
other parts of the world that would
suffer If the message is sent to
potential aggressors that we will stand
idly by and watch them brutalize their
neighbors we will never do that
order just before we proceed
um a great many people still wish to
participate in this statement and we've
already been underway for 42 minutes
there's a lot other business that the
house has to transact for the rest of
today so can I make a plea for short
questions which would then allow the
foreign secretary to give short answers
John Hull thank you madam Deputy speaker
will my right honorable friend join me
in congratulating president zielinski
for engaging directly with
parliamentarians such as myself at the
Council of Europe and he spoke openly
about his needs there and it was an
answer to a question of mine that he
said that the need for missile defense
systems was he had only 10 of what he
needed
well I do uh I do congratulate president
zielinski on his engagement with uh
Partners both bilaterally and
multilaterally and I would like to put
on record uh my thanks for the work that
my honorable friend does uh in ensuring
that these issues are brought to the
attention and the huge amount of effort
that he puts into the UK's position on
the council group
the statement mentioned Syria as one of
those countries at the United Nations
that has given Russia Comfort but it's
not Syrian civilians that have taken
that stance in fact Madam Deputy speaker
they are the very people who know
equally to anyone in this world of
Putin's violence so can I ask the
foreign secretary what he's doing at the
United Nations or elsewhere to widen the
consensus that all civilians in our
world deserve protection from Putin's
violence including Syrian civilians
from the speaker she makes an incredibly
important point we have seen the
leadership in Russia Putin bringing pain
and harm on Russian people we have seen
Assad bringing pain and harm on Syrian
people we know it is not done in their
name it is not done with their say so
and she's absolutely right that
civilians around the world are suffering
because of the the poor decisions of
their their brutal leadership both in
Moscow and in Syria
Richard Drex
by can I welcome my
son delighted to see he's still there I
understand that we hear an awful lot
about what we and what the Americans are
giving in direct help to the ukrainians
can you clarify to the house to the
house exactly what other NATO countries
like Germany and France are actually
giving to Ukraine and the scale of it
I remember Deputy speaker time prevents
me from going into the level of detail
uh that uh that my honorable friend has
asked for but I would reassure the house
that whilst the UK is second only to the
United States American direct Military
Support uh other countries around the
world around Europe are very very much
providing supports to Ukraine and have
uh uh have responded and responded with
alacrity at the Russian invasion of
Ukraine
both through NATO and through of various
institutions including the G7 we have
become closer as allies and we will I'm
sure continue to stand in solidarity in
our support for ukrainians and defense
their Homeland yeah
George you like many
many quarter by the homes for Ukraine
scheme arrived in the UK with the
Ukrainian cars and they hope to return
home as soon it is safe to do so
will the foreign secretary speak to his
colleagues in DFT about the Urgent to
drop in or extending the required
requirements to exchange Ukrainian
number plates for UK players beyond the
current six months period which is
causing unnecessary stress to those
affected
I'll take a note of the of the point
that he has made and I'm sure my
colleagues in transport will have done
so also
Andrew salou
tree uh imposed sanctions on Evan
rayabov a Russian security official who
was shown to have abused Russian females
protesting against Ukraine and would
this not show that our sanctions reach
reaches even Junior Russians who abuse
Russian protesters like that
I'm sure he will be unsurprised to say
that we don't discuss future sanctions
designations but the house and my
department will have heard the name that
he has mentioned and the circumstances
under which that sanction might be
considered
Kevin Jones I'm Joseph Smith can I thank
the foreign secretary for his uh
statement he mentioned in his statement
enlaw which has been tremendously
effective in uh Ukraine but is also a
fact that we haven't yet put in a
contract for renewaling just the stocks
the the for the UK Army but also for any
future use in Ukraine why is that when
will the contract be signed
my understanding is that we've given
letters of complex to the supply chain
of end-laws which will stimulate the
future production
um and that we will of course always
take actions that ensures that not only
we are able to support Ukraine as the
defense of their Homeland but we do so
without detrimenting our ability to
defend ourselves Dr Luke Evans
speaking the U.N estimate suggests that
the Black Sea grain initiative has
indirectly saved 100 million people from
falling into extreme poverty so when he
goes to the G7 meeting on Thursday will
he be raising this particular topic and
looking at what support we can put into
the key partner of turkey to try and
make sure that Russia released their
suspension of this deal
uh I speak with my Turkish counterpart
regularly on this issue and others they
are I know very committed to ensure that
those green exports continue and I will
continue discussing with them uh how we
can ensure that continues beyond the
current lifestyle of this agreement
uh water supply so can I ask uh the
Secretary of State what more his
government is doing to ensure your
cleanings get access to clean water both
through expertise and funding yeah thank
you
uh The Honorable lady makes an
incredibly important point about the
ability to repair infrastructure as I
say I spoke to his Majesty's Ambassador
in Kiev uh just this afternoon about the
speed with which Ukrainian Municipal
workers are repairing that
infrastructure remarkable uh speed with
which they do that uh actually I might
take this opportunity to respond to a
specific question that uh the right
Uncle gentleman made about humanitarian
assistance including 856 portable
generators to support power for
essential public services in Ukraine
Robert Collins
okay I'd like to pay tribute to the
extraordinary achievements of the
Ukrainian Air Force and the
circumstances today could
a foreign secretary uh assure me that he
will be given consideration to what
support he can give them so the aerial
Dimension is not forgotten
I can assure him we will consider that
I'm very proud of the fact that we've
supplied number of amaran missiles uh
specifically to help defend themselves
the ukrainians defend themselves against
tax from the air will keep that
constantly under review Richard Ford
thank you madam Deputy speaker in a
statement issued in March the government
said it had created an electricity
Network support task force for Ukraine
which brought together UK commercial
suppliers and the energy networks
Association the then foreign secretary
and right honorable member for Southwest
Norfolk said we will keep the lights on
in Ukraine
okay and and I thank the right honorable
uh Secretary of State for uh talking
about 856 mobile generators but I wonder
can you update the house on what part
the electricity Network support task
force is now having so that we can honor
the former foreign secretaries pledge
well we continue to work with the
ukrainians to uh help them keep the
lights on to help them keep their water
going and not just in the here and now
but also to help their energy resilience
uh in the future as I say we will ensure
that our support to Ukraine adapts to uh
account for their changing needs and
circumstances
Mark Pritchard
is not the case that Putin's
weaponization of food should be a
wake-up call for those African countries
many of them commonwealth countries that
are perhaps inadvertently bought into
the false Narrative of Putin over the
war and recently abstained rather than
voted for the U.N resolution and they
should understand that Russia and Putin
are unreliable partner for Africa
thank you
the whole world
including Commonwealth Nations our
friends in Africa in other parts of the
global South should recognize that
Vladimir Putin is no friend of those he
is using their hunger as leverage in his
war against the ukrainians and they
should see Lao they should be able to
see what is happening we will continue
to help get grain out of Ukraine to help
them put food on their tables
foreign
which I think is incredibly important
but with special reference to the
humanitarian Aid passage can the foreign
secretary confirm that there are still
corridors where medical supplies and
goods and supplies are still reaching
those innocent people caught in the
midst of kittens despicable criminal
attacks
um speaker The Honorable gentleman makes
an incredibly important Point as well as
putting the money on the table we have
to make sure that our support gets to
the people that need it we all
constantly look at ways of ensuring that
is the case he will understand that I
will refrain from going into details
about the eight corridors that are
currently in uh place
Deputy speaker as the foreign sector
will know the attack in February was not
the first invasion of Ukraine by Russia
and they've been occupying illegally
territory for the last eight years
including the Crimea therefore is he
clear in his own mind that any strikes
on you on Crimean territory in
particular on Sebastopol Naval
facilities is a strike on Ukrainian
territory not on Russian territory
my right honorable friend makes an
incredibly important point this conflict
did not start in February the most
recent phase of this conflict started in
February but there have been ukrainians
who have been attacked abused and
occupied by Russian forces for many many
years before that we must never lose
sight of that fact
Deputy speaker my right honorable
friends spoke about Iran supplying
drones to Russia to attack
ukrainians can he say a little bit more
about the implications that has on the
nuclear deal that we have with Iraq with
that the world has with Iran
uh he raises an important point but it
is fundamentally a separate issue our
resolve to prevent I mean the
international resolve to prevent prevent
further nuclear proliferation uh remains
unchanged we will continue working with
our allies to ensure that Iran does not
acquire a nuclear weapon but we will
also ensure that we prevent Iran and
indeed anyone else from exporting arms
to Russia that are being used in this
conflict in Ukraine
sucky butter you madam Deputy speaker is
incredibly worrying that Iran is
undermining the Ukrainian defense and
putting Ukrainian civilians at risk by
supplying Russia with Chinese drones I
understand that we've sanctioned three
Iranian commanders but can my right and
will friend confirm that he and the
Prime Minister are willing to go further
if needed and he'll be raising the issue
when he meets his counterparts of the G7
listeners
I can assure my right honorable friend
that we will continue to keep our
sanctions package under review and we
will respond to any further breaches of
the uh United Nations security Council
resolution and that we will ensure that
the message is sent that those those
people on those countries sorry those
companies that's that are supplying arms
to Russia in breach of U.N security
Council resolutions will be responded to
finally
Brandon Clark Smith
The Madam Deputy speaker and uh can I
say how truly astounded I am at The
Bravery of the tens of thousands of
ukrainians who have stepped up to defend
their Homeland and can my right
honorable friend uh assure me that the
UK is doing all it can with its allies
to make sure that they receive the
necessary training for them to be able
to do their jobs
at the beginning of the year at the
United Nations I said the ukrainians
would defend them defend their Homeland
ferociously they have done exactly that
my respect for those people both the
professional soldiers
air Personnel Sailors and the Ukrainian
Armed Forces before The Invasion and
those who
teachers Builders catwalk models former
politicians who have taken up arms to
defend their country have the most
enormous respect from across the world I
can assure my honorable friend that we
will continue to support them as they
defend themselves against this illegal
unprovoked and barbaric invasion
thank you that concludes the uh
statement from the foreign secretary I'm
pausing for a moment to allow members
who intend to leave the chamber to do so
swiftly and quietly in order that
in order that we can proceed to our next
item of business
and to give the